de la siguiente tabla es una función de
x recordemos que para que sea función de
x debemos tener para cada valor de x de
entrada en nuestra cajita de función y
de x debemos tener sólo un valor de
salida y si esto se cumple entonces es
una función si por cada valor de x hay
un valor de ella
esto es una función
pero funciona
si tenemos que para cada equis que entra
hay una cajita tenemos como resultado
más de un valor
entonces esto no es función no funciona
ok veamos nuestra tabla
vemos que de entrada aún no tenemos
salida 1 y también vemos que parece
entrada 1 tenemos otro valor de salida 2
para un solo valor de entrada tenemos
dos valores de salida
así que tenemos nuestro 1
entra a nuestra cajita y aquí con la
tabla vemos que va a tener un 1 y
también va a tener un 2 así que esto
pues evidentemente no es funciona
es función